وين احييكم مشاهدينا من جديد تعتبر الاشهر
السته الماضيه استثنائيه بالنسبه لتنظيم
داعش وبالتحديد لقادته الذين اصبحوا
يتساقطون واحدا تلو الاخر اوراق الشجر في
فصل الخريف كما يقول البعض فقد اعلن
التنظيم نفسه
مقتل زعيم او اعلى
زعيمه ابو الحسن القرش الذي اختر زعيما
لتنظيف مارس الماضي لافتا الى تعيين خليفه
ومرافقه وهو مرافقيه بعد ما حصلته من قبل
مقاتلين محليين في بلده جاسم في سوريا
منتصف اكتوبر المنصرم وقد تحول قاده
التنظيم الى هدف متوتر الاستراتيجيه الضرب
من السماء التي ماتت تتبعها امريكا في
حربها وتتبعها في حربها المستمره ضد تنظيم
الارهابي قبل ايام فقط لنا البيتاكون مقتل
زعيم داعش في سوريا العقل بعد استهدافه
بضربه جويه من طائره مسيره اثناء تنقوله
على درجه ناريه في منطقه
جنديرسبي ريفي حلب الشمالي وجاءت هذه
الحادثه بعد اقل من شهر من عمليه انزال
نفذتها قوات التحالف الدولي بقياده ميركا
في مدينه جرابلس حيث اعتقلت هاني احمد
الكرسي الذي يعرف باسم سليم وكنا يشتغل في
السابق بمنصب ولرقاء في التنظيمه
هاتانيا الحادثتان مشاهدينا كان قد
صديقهما ضربه امريكيه اكبر في يناير من
عام 2022 حيث قتلت قوتنا امريكيه زعم داعش
عبد الله قرداش والمعروف بسمه وابراهيم
القرشي بعد تنفيذ عمليه
في المكان الذي كان يختبئ فيه شمال
محافظات ادلب سوريا
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا من القاهره
الباحث في شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه ماهر
فرغليها من الرباط الدكتور ادريس الكمبوري
البحث في شؤون الجماعات المغترفه اهلا بكم
من القاهره معك استاذ ماهر في الواقع في
المقال من مقالاتك او في
تعليقك بالاحرى على مقتل قائد داعش الاخير
ابو الحسن القرشي تحدث وكانك المحت الى ان
الموضوع قد يكون تصفيه من الداخل همم اوضح
لنا اكثر هذه النقطه
بعد التحيه لشيادتك وللساده المشاهدين
الكريم من المغرب
المعلومات التي ادلى بها مصادر يعني داخل
التنظيم على بعض صفحاتهم ان العمليه كانت
معركه مع بعض فصال المعارضه السوريه في
قريه جاسم في ريف درعا هذه المعركه همم
ادت في النهايه الى حصار زعيم داعش همم
ابو الحسن الهاشمي ومن ثم هو فجر نفسه هو
بعض اتباعه في هذه المعارض السوريه اذن هي
مع المعارضه لم تكن لا مع الجيش السوري
ولا مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يعني
هنا همم المساله هنا من ادلى بما على مكان
همم على مكان زعيم داعش همم تحدثوا ايضا
على انه زعيم داعش كان يعقد جلس سالم
محاكمه بعض اتباعه في هذه القريه ومن ثم
ادلى احد اتباعهم معلومه وصلت الى المعرض
السوريه من الجيش السوري الحره الذين
ذهبوا لح هذا المكان ومن ثم انتهت العمليه
بمقتل هذا الزعيم اذا العمليه من داخل ال
همم
اسئله حول بالضبط تطرح اسئله همم دكتور
ادريس همم عن همم المستوى الاستخبارات
لانه داعش كان من التنظيمات التي توصف
بالقويه ولها مستوى استخبارات يوما كانها
من التجول مقدتها على الاقل تمكن قدتها من
التجول واعضاءها من التحرك ومن التجنيد
ولكن عمليات القتل المتتاليه هل توحي بان
هناك ضعف على مستوى التنظيم وربما هذا هذه
علامه او مؤشر لقربه نهايته او هذا مستمر
طب لمن بالتاكيد يعني بعد مقتل ابي بكر
البغدادي الذي كان يمثل نوع من الكاريزما
داخل التنظيم من الطبيعي ان تظهر بعض
الاجنحه الداخليه وتصفيه الحسابات يعني
داخل المجموعه من الاطراف خاصه بان هذا
الصراع يعني كان سلفا موجودا في عهد
البغدادي لكنه كتما لان كانت هناك يعني
سباق حول الزحامات حول الرئاسه الولايات
حول بعض المبادئ والقضايا العقديه مثل
يعني همم التكفير مثل همم يعني همم
[موسيقى]
مثلا اغتيال الاستهلاف الشيعه او حولويات
في ما يتعلق بالخطه العالميه لكن بطبيعه
الحلم يعني الشخص المؤسس لابد ان نوع من
التفكك وهذا بالتجه الى تشتت المركزيه
التي كانت لدى التنظيم وبالتالي سوف يجعل
اكثر عرضه للاختراع قناه اعتقد بان يعني
هذا ما يحصل الان في التنظيم
ويبدو ان انه مرشح ليكون اكثر تفكنا يعني
في المستقبل همم القريب خاصه وان يعني ما
يحصل كما قال يعني الاستاذ ماهر ربما قد
يكون هذا التصفيه حسابات داخليه لكن هذا
غير مؤكد لان انا في اعتقادي لان التنظيم
يحاول دائما ان يوجه رساله معينه الى
اتباعه والى الاطراف الدوله الاخرى على
اساس انه محصن من الداخل وبالتالي يا اما
مقتل الزعيم الى تصفيه الحسابات الداخليه
او انه في الشجره نفسه عندما وصل اليه
العدو اذا في جميع الحالات هو التنظيم
يعني محصنا من الداخل واعتقد ان دعايه
البيولوجيه اكثر مما تعكس الواقع داخل
التنظيم السيد ماهر الاختراقات هذا التفتت
كما البعد ربما هل هو مؤشر لبدايه نهايه
هذا التنظيم اتحدث عن التنظيم كمكون كجسم
ولا اتحدث عن الارهاب كفكره هذه تناقش
ربما وتاخذ ساعه كبيره ولكن تنظيم كما
عرفنا هل يمكن ان يتفتت لدرجه همم موته
انا اريد ان يعني اشرح للساده المشاهدين
ال- ال- الفتره الحرجه التي يمر بها تنظيم
داعش الان واحد هو فقد زعماء المؤسسين
يعني داعش منذ ابو بكر البغدادي حتى الان
فقط اكثر من زعيم وعلى فترات متقاربه وليس
من الصف الاول فقط الزعيم الرمز لكنه الصف
الثاني والثالث ابو علي الانباري همم نايف
جبور غير من الزعماء القصور الذين قالوا
التنظيم هذا واحد ثانيا فقد التمويل
الاكثر لانه فقد السيطره على الارض يعني
كان وسيطر الارض يتفقد الارض من سنه
انهارت الجيش المركزي لداعش
والذي كان يطلق عليه جيش النخبه
ثالث شيء يمر بدايه عشان انه تحول من
التمكين على الارض الى الانتشار هذا ادى
الى مشكلات كثيره جدا والى الى الى فقده
مقاتلين كثيرين جدا قبض عليهم او ذهبوا
الى الصحاري همم الرابع شئ في في هذه
المساله انه حدثت له اختراقات داخليه يعني
امنيه
توصلوا من خلال الى القيادات وشيء مهم
الاخير الذي وجد عاش الان هو الصراعات
التياراتيه كما تحدث دكتور ادريس طياراتيه
لا ده داعش داعش ليس شيئا واحدا داعش كما
قلنا واسلفت من قبل اربعه التيارات داخل
داعش طيار ابو محمد الفرقان الذي كان يقود
العمليه الاعلاميه وقد قتل وتيار ابو جعفر
حطاب من تونس وهو طيار يطلق عليه التيار
الحازمي
وهو متشدد ايضا قتل
والتيار بن علي وهو طيار نوعا ما اهدى
قليلا من الطيارين السابقين وايضا قتل
تركي بن عاليه التيار الاخير هو التيار
الذي كان يقوده الزعيم السابق الذي قتل
لتنظيم داعش هو تيار متشدد يؤمن بافكار
ايضا تنزيل احكام عدم العسر بالجهل
والتنزيل احكام الكافره على شاكين الدوله
هذه الصراع الفكري الهيلوجي الداخل
الاربعه التيارات ادى الى سرعات بينيه
كثيره جدا اذا هذا هو داعش الان لماذا
السؤال المطروح الان هل هذه الصراعات
الداخليه
قادره ان تنهي التنظيم بشكلها الذي عرفناه
به على الاقل
لا هي اضعافات التنظيم لكن هو حاول ان
يتجاوز ذلك واحد بحشمه الزعيم حشم كل
المسائل الفكريه بي ان تيار واحد يقود
التنظيم فكريا ثانيا ان يقوم بعمل لجان
علميه جديده ويعيد هيكله التنظيم الى بدلا
من جيش النخبه الى جيش خالد بن الوليد ولا
الاعتماد على الذهاب المنفرد او على
الخلايا المنفرده وشلش انا يقوم بعمليات
خلافه سبرانيه على الانترنت وترويج
وعمليات ترويج وقرصنه وعمليات قتال جديده
همم عبر شبكات على الانترنت اذا هو حاول
ان يتجاوز ذلك خلال الفتره الماضيه وان
يتمدد في الافرع جديده يعني يذهب الى
منطقه وسط اسيا يعود يحاول العوده الى
اليمن يحاول ان يعود في غرب افريقيا كان
له نشاط كبير جدا في افريقيا في الحقيقه
وفي همم اماره الساحل والصحراء
هل تعتقد بان بمقتل داعش الاخير هي نقطه
همم همم ولاده جديده لمكون جديد او
استمرار اللي داعش ولكن ببعض التاثيرات
على المستوى الاستراتيجي على مستوى
التخطيط على المستوى اللوجستي حضرتك كيف
ترى مستقبل هذا المكون
امم لا ينبغي ربط مقتل اي زعيم داخل تنظيم
جهادي او تنظيم ارهابي او حتى تنظيم
اسلامي
بحياه التنظيم او موت يعني لو بدانا نجمات
احوال المسلمين مثلا عندما قتل
1949 كان همم
جامعه الاخوان سوف تنتهي لكن ثمانيه عقود
فيما بعد وكذلك الامر بالنسبه
في تنظيم القاعده لكن اعتقد بان يعني
الميزان الشخصي لبعض او القيادات في
التنظيمات الجهاديه قد تؤثر الماء على
هياكل التنظيم وعلى
البيولوجيا وهذا ما سوف يحدث على على
مستوى تنظيم داعش التنظيم يعني انتهى على
مستوى الشرق الاوسط لكنه الان ينتشر على
الصعيد الافريقي وهناك يعني محاولات حجيجه
لكي يركز قدمي على مستوى القاره السمراء
وفي الفترات الاخير يعني في مارس الماضي
اعلنا بان التنظيم همم انشا ولايه جديده
في القاره في الساحل وفي الموزمبيق والان
هناك تمدد كبير على الصعيد يعني البحيره
تشاد الكاميرون نيجر الموزمبيق بوجهين
قسوه مناطق وبلدان لم يكن في في السابق في
العقد الاخير قد التمدد اليها اليوم
داعش والاخوان قد يقول البعض دكتور بان
الاخوان لديهم عقود من التاسيس ومن التوسع
ومن الانتشار همم القاعده كذلك منذ
ثمانينات ولكن داعش يبدو اا جديد نسبيه
يعني نشاه مع اجتياح همم امريكا على
العراق يعني في سنه همم في ناس وبالتالي
همم كيف يمكن لداعش او ما الذي يمتلك داعش
ليكون اليوم في صفوف هذه التنظيمات التي
يعتبر
قويه وخطيره
لا ما انا اعتقد ان الامر لا يتعلق باي
ولاده جديده وانما يعني بنوع من
الاستمراريه لفكر جهادي موجود سلفا لان
هذه التنظيمات تستفيد من بعضها البعض
وتقبس من من تمضيراتها لننسى بان يعني
القائد الايديولوجيا النظريه عند تنظيم
داعش كان قد اخذ من يعني تنظيم القاعده
ومجموعه من المنظرين همم الجيولوجين
التحقوا بالتنظيم واصبحوا رافدا من روافد
الايديولوجيا كذلك التنظيم داعش استفاده
ايضا من يعني تنظيم القاعده من حيث
الخبران من حيث الاستراتيجيه من حيث
الاقصى ايضا هو انا اعتقد الان بانه بانه
تنظيم داعش سوف يستفيد من ماضيه على مستوى
سوريا والعراق لكي لا يكرر بعض الاخطاء في
القاره الافريقيه لكن هذا لانه مرشح لكي
يشهد من الانقسام ويتحول الى تنظيمات
محليه على الصعيد
البلدان الافريقيه
بدايه او قبل بانوراما لتغطيه فوز المغرب
وبهذه المناسبه همم مبروك دكتور ادريس
اترشح الفوز ومن ثم كذلك الترشح همم اول
شكرا لكم جزيلا شكرا على المشاركه وكل ما
تفضلت ما به من معلومات دكتور ادريس
الكمبوري الباحث في شؤون الجماعه المتطرفه
ومن القاهره الباحث في شؤون الجماعات
المتطرفه ماهر فرغلي شكرا لكم